cruz dias a todos amico si viene nido
sin questo come cazzo se disco mi
ricordo aveva affanculo
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj sono arrivate nelle lettere a
casa che mi chiedevano di farlo quindi
che cazzo succede che cazzo carichi che
t'ha dato il permesso paranormale
caricamento tanto per cominciare agazzi
comunque new game
perché allora sembra un pappone zio
fantastico non essere spaventato io sono
qui con te ma se televita ragazze un po
meglio e non è che mi calmi perché con
lotito sta piangendo perché perché
perché c'è un pappone nel mio letto
ragazze ragazzi c'è una roba sto
piangendo sono io questo madonna che
ciuffo sexy e c'è un pò pone nel mio
letto fantastico ti sei togliendoti deve
calpestare il pube a questi sono i miei
amici
ciao amici come state io sono fa vj sto
piangendo quindi mismo kohler ho addosso
però ecco infatti non ho capito qual è
il problema ascolta pappone ha tanto
visto che quello sguardo che figo potrei
denunciati per stalking e per mancanza
di pene amico mio uno dei due è un
ragazzo che un giorno si ritrovò con un
pappone e memory a caso una lacrima
strappa storia non ho capito
ciao possiamo partire o non ha mica
mezzo già finito il gameplay ragazzi non
sono anche partiti ma che bello regalo
che allora siamo nella stanza nella mia
stanza a questa è la mia stanza freak
mouse da un world tutto a si può girare
fantastico ciao zio che bello che se ti
stacco le budella ok non è difficile
perfetto l'avevo capito che si che sono
giocattoli più belli che io abbia mai
visto lega questo lo voglio
assolutamente clicca qui per correre nel
percorrere curve che gran figata minchia
chi no vabbè hanno aggiunto la
possibilità di muoversi in file metef
regis ragazzi il gioco dell'amica qui
per chiudere la porta non percorrere a
tre trofei
attenzione ascolta attentamente se senti
respirare chiudi la porta a porta chiuso
che non sentiva spirare usa la tua
torcia che non sento respirare quindi
sulla mia torcia
mi piace questa casa io piango e muoio
questa la cosa l'ho capita però non ho
capito perché però va beh una donna come
si aprono le porte in modo bruttissimo
ho capito non si [ __ ] i
suggerimenti su giocati io non ho ancora
capito quale ragas tardo di merda che
che si è ficcato sotto le coperte cosa
vuoi dalla mia vita vuoi guardarmi
mentre d'oro non pervertito stronzo
treno sia il pappone di prima però non
ne sono completamente sicuro comunque io
posso fare qualcosa ma si apre e si
chiude quindi fantastico come le gambe
di domande tratto sulle tre di notte su
così vincendo a cazzo [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok perché devo avere un cazzo di maniaco
sotto il violetto regate mica che poi un
pupazzo prova bene ma pace qualcuno c'è
solo devo guardarmi indietro e basta fai
la guardia come sole 4 rino attragga
mancano due ore ho vinto la prima nota
il problema è che non ho capito qual è
il problema visto gioco su chiave lo è
che bello mi dispiace zio si vede che ci
tiene proprio a in gruppo armi da dietro
però non mi dispiace
sì sì prima notte nottata di merda
ragazzi anche quando andavo a scuola che
c'hanno le verifiche le passavo
costituito non si fermerà finché tu non
lo troverai e vabbè dove cazzo è perché
c'è in casa per davvero si colta
cappello viola tu che sei fashion nel
vestirsi questi sono i miei amici ho
capito fiat in a il culo andati sopra
c'è un pappone sul mio orologio a
pendolo ma che storia triste non lo so
che cercavi il cesso a malvagna da
un'altra parte comunque gaga dove vuoi
io vado sonda riguarda niente non è non
è quello il ces quello il divano togliti
che devo bere la mia vita
cazzo sta facendo così perché fai così
prima [ __ ] manco avessi trovato però
vabbè tua madre [ __ ] [ __ ] della
sorella di un incidente stradale
madrid sono sì e fatic al fegato non ha
fatto non ho neanche visto che cos'era
ma è stato tragico veramente tribal è
stato alquanto beh ti regalo un
ventilatore zio che serve in questo
periodo quindi non mi fare spaventare
grazie dai notte due partiamo questa
notte due vogliamo di finirla perché già
mi sta sul cazzo capito ma quel tizio
che sta sul letto quale santo benedetto
san gennaro è piazze successo ce n'erano
tre da un [ __ ] che che c'era ce
n'erano tre fanta ha chiamato gli amici
hanno capito che c'è un party e quindi
ha chiamato gli amici fantastico bello
sto già mi piace meno male che è che che
ne fanno sempre di nuovi di file nate
tre ditte bello c'è così tanta
differenza tra la notte una notte due la
notte una rara cagata la notte due
impossibile che hai visto troppo naruto
quello era un bell'uomo però c'era un
tizio c'è un maniaco per caso vabbè
tanto per cambiare come se non avessi
bisogno aveva detto agli amici che di
notte mi sentivo solo nel letto ho
bisogno di compagnia ma cazzo non
intendevo questo ma io posso andare vi
quando non posso ne ha ma si chiude e
[ __ ] si chiude
scott charlton tu che fai fai da tè
freddi se nei fatti ben quattro amati
picchiava quando eri piccolo fammi
capire voglio capire la tua infanzia i
problemi alla tua testa come si sono
evoluti nel tempo solo questa solo per
curiosità
grazie complimenti per i bei personaggi
che crei di detroit e sfruttato un vaso
cosa non aver sentito ragazzi non capito
e non c'è più paranormal vasi calmi
calmi
lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
non so se ho detto lo sapevo è però lo
sapeva perché cazzo è un nano quello che
sto comandando per che cammina come
fosse un bambino c'è il suo no ok ho
sentito rumori i ragazzi non capisco
quando mi devo quando quando devo
chiudere la porta non lo capisco non
capisco non ce la farò mai a passano 3 2
bene va bene va bene va bene e spunta o
certo grazie che credo che sia e alla
pesca o da culo a e non era il riflesso
ecco perché avevo visto qualcuno fuori
dal riflesso di quel [ __ ] perfetto
ok se ne è andato che culo sono le tre
sole tre mancano solo tre ore non ce la
farò mai nella vita perché non lo so
fare su mi piace questo gioco era blu
possiamo giocare nello kitty vi prego
adesso mi sto veramente cagare
e cazzo è successo
quale nome di contrà burci non trovino
chiuso che cazzo devo fare che chi cazzo
sei tu lurido pavia già bastardo lo
stato c'è una volta nell'armadio una
volta nell'armadio l'armadio non lo apro
ecco lo sapevo
ho chiuso anche la porta nel mentre ma
non è servito un cazzo bene fa non ho
niente era solo poi one direction bene
mi sto impegnando al massimo riga più di
così non posso fare
ve lo dico adesso adesso c'è per forza
c'era qualcuno perché ho sentito quanto
sto così dichiara mi va in cancrena al
braccio cosa non ho capito non capito
quanto devo stare così male
no perché poi arriva dall'altra parte
ragazzi mi è piaciuto molto è stato un
bel gioco più bello bello bello bello ma
proprio che lo ri giocherei volentieri
tra 5 e 10 minuti poi sneijder freddy's
4 complimenti per questo gioco bello
grazie ragazzi di aver meno consigliato
perché mi sono i dati miliardo di
consigli nell'ultima settimana è stato
un grandissimo videogame con troppi jobs
jobs chi che pronuncia che fa più paura
del gioco stesso per un culo vi episodio
spero che vi do vi sia piaciuto nemmeno
a voi perché
a me è proprio un cazzo è quindi ragazzi
servito è piaciuto ma solito lasciato
quanto mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e con il video tra tale
descrizione non mi piace se non volete
ritrovarvi qualcuno dalla porta di
camera vostra di notte sono notte non
dorme nessun regalo
qualcuno dorme con me dovresti discreti
ci vediamo al prossimo vinto 6 da
ragazze